e adesso la seconda parte Ciao ragazzi
arrivederci arrivederci
[Applauso]
siamo a Milano Centrale eh vi starete
chiedendo il perché tutti i vlog mi
aiuti ultimamente partono da Milano
Centrale Me lo sto chiedendo anch'io
comunque Ragazzi perché una mia fan che
si chiama Martina mi ha scritto nei DM
Io vorrei farmi un tatuaggio che in
qualche modo rappresenti te perché sei
stata una parte importante della mia
vita Un bel messaggio un bel messaggio
infatti mi piace sempre quando ricevo
messaggi del genere Ovviamente un
tatuaggio è una cosa molto strana questa
ragazza mi ha chiesto quindi di fare un
disegno per lei in modo che lei se lo
potesse tatuare il sottoscritto che fa
veramente schifo a disegnare ha risposto
Ciao Martina non so quanto tu ti voglia
male ma io so solo sgranocchiare vi
faccio vedere cosa ho fatto a dare della
Giusta una volta dai un cucciolo Guarda
guarda
[Musica]
Comunque ho pensato di fare le cose un
po' meglio Ho chiamato una mia amica che
si chiama Nadine che fa la tatuatrice e
la disegnatrice e ho detto Nadine
Aiutami a fare un bel disegno per questa
mia fan in modo che possiamo tatuarlo un
qualcosa di decente tu che sei una
tatuatrice non ti senti di dover avere
una responsabilità incredibile su quello
che stai facendo sul corpo degli altri
Sì infatti c'è sempre qualcosa di
rappresentativo per il mio canale
potrebbero essere le cuffie e delle
cuffie tatuate su una ragazza mi sembra
un po' una cacata mostruosa facciamo
qualcosa di più figo lo Slenderman è
abbastanza rappresentativo Dammi una
mano allora come si può iniziare a fare
un tatuaggio e la faccia mi sembra già
che ci potrebbe già essere posso fare
una cosa poi la cancella certo Indovina
chi è Forse Ecco
Ehi dove stai andando
ecco qua Facciamo questo raga è
bellissimo ma sto male secondo me io
devo smettere di fare lo youtuber ma
perché faccio lo youtuber [__]
quando potevo fare tranquillamente i
tatuaggi con Nadine apriamo uno studio
Aspetta aspetta c'ho l'estro Topolino
ragazzi pazzesco che dire Ragazzi allora
questo è un buon punto di partenza
ovviamente vanno fatti i tentacoli va
fatta della roba qui ragazzi il
tatuaggio è finito ve lo faremo vedere
tra poco e adesso siamo a Milano
Centrale perché appunto Martina sta
arrivando per fare il tatuaggio noi
siamo venuti qua a prenderla e andiamo
in studio a fare il tatuaggio Ciao
ragazzi è il momento in cui conosciamo
Martina e vediamo se si può fare questa
cosa incredibile
Oh mio Dio
Ciao Piacere
sei pronta tu non hai visto niente l'hai
visto il tatuaggio però tu non devi fare
tu non devi fare niente lascio fare a me
perché sei impari Mi levi lo stipendio
però
siamo arrivati al il tatuaggio studio vi
lascio il link in description perché
Gabel scia ospitati Ovviamente per fare
questo video Infatti Ringraziamo gabe e
lascio appunto i link in descrizione del
tatuaggio studio che è diventato molto
più fai del corridoio niente di
incredibile proprio bene Andiamo alla
Nadine Ti presento la dea che la ragazza
che farà
[Musica]
lei è Nadine che non è per niente timina
Nadine
Nadine che la ragazza inizia il video
Quindi abbiamo finito il tatuaggio
presentatevi presentatevi
la bozza manca il disegno definitivo vai
È bellissimo è bellissimo È bellissimo
veramente bello eh L'ha detto l'ha detto
abbiamo l'ha detto
[Musica]
perché io Vabbè mi impegno la mano solo
per prezzi in un certo tipo questo è
solo il disegno e poi c'è Nadine 500
euro Fatemi sapere 800 euro vi faccio il
disegnino eh ovviamente per Martina è
gratis però ragazzi
802 euro Avete tutti Non mi ricordo se
ho spiegato il perché del tatuaggio in
pasta stanno facendo la ditta di
traslochi ragazzi Martina perché
mi prendo questa responsabilità non mi
prendo questa esperienza
boh Eh secondo me è stato il video che
ha dato via il via a tutta la trafila
degli Horror è stato sostanzialmente il
mio primo video da solo fine è che c'è
molto da ridere
grazie
vuoi tatuarti Cosa devi fare il ragno
qua io vi vorrei tatuare Oggi andiamo
andiamo
a fare il tuo lavoro sembra nei video
che faceva mio padre quando ero piccolo
inquadrava e fumava
34k ma si può vedere il tatuaggio Ma che
professionalità è una link ai copritutto
manco dovesse essere permanente
giusto Scusami
Martina no per niente Ok mattina siamo a
un buon 12% del tatuaggio
[Musica]
Ah A che punto siamo qua Ma se non mi
piace lo rifacciamo okay
[Musica]
Minchia È incredibile che ho disegnato
io sta roba
quando vuoi quando hai bisogno mi chiedi
Ok grazie a posto cosa stai facendo
metti un po' di vaselina nel mentre
aspetto eh Sì infatti
Fai attenzione a dire determina ragazzi
giudicate voi A me piace molto figo Non
è bellissima ragazzi cioè non farei io
ti ho detto Me lo farei io questo io
pensavo che di fare un tatuaggio
significativo per me perché non ho mai
fatto cioè per me Nel senso di YouTube
qui Avrei fatto una cosa del genere
quindi non lo posso più fare io che ce
l'hai tu ormai me ne vado Quindi dovrò
fare un'altra cosa tipo tipo Cat Mario
Boh ma Ringrazia che c'è lei Eh perché
sennò vu cazzi che veniva giù quindi
ragazzi il video finisce qua grazie a
Martina Per adesso sì Ehm tatuata un mio
disegno e adesso la seconda parte Ciao
ragazzi arrivederci arrivederci